the stream of refugees crossing the
border now is almost constant and it's
increasing all the time
it is snowing here it is bitterly cold
but at least it's safe
almost everyone has left someone behind
decisions they'll never forget
i leave my family i leave my mom
mom
was crying and telling me that
that maybe she never see me again
it was it was small scary words
which i
heard in my life
i'm still
i'm still scared i'm still afraid that
i can't
can't see her anymore
i'm left behind on my life i left behind
all my dreams
for a few there is sheer relief at being
reunited with family
most though arrived dazed unsure of
what's next
i hope we will win soon the war will end
and we come home again
at the moment the authorities here are
coping there is enough food there is
enough shelter there's enough help
but what if the numbers double triple
quadruple even it's fair to say that at
the moment
you know the romanians have kind of got
it sorted it's a pretty good operation
they they move people here
as quick as they can do there's food hot
food
drinks for them they process them
buses free buses and then into the local
towns and villages
but the numbers are getting more it was
eight percent
more refugees yesterday than the day
before that
and there's already been more today
again
on one side of the border there are
humans killing humans
just the other side humans helping
humans
there's something quite life-affirming
in the way eastern europeans are doing
everything they can to look after their
neighbours
alice debunker sky news on the ukrainian
romanian border